let's cut to the chase why am I here
your primary target is your old rival
from the Cold War
Nikolai andrakovich now Andrew kovich
has been leading
Jackson Jackson
[Music]
hey did you see that that looked like
Busta Rhymes and Maya Angelou had a baby
yeah yeah that was one jacked up looking
oh
oh you just dropped the n-word but
you're not an N lucky for you there's a
way to avoid these situations
introducing the new smartphone
application the knee graph finally a
technology specifically designed to help
you determine whether or not you can
drop the n-bomb I can say it
we can all say it
not in this lifetime to see your knee
graph just enter your name age and color
of your skin or just the color of your
skin
I've got the knee graph on my phone and
my iPad my phone says I can't ever say
it my iPad says I can never say it but
bigger the knee graph can you say the
n-word I can say all day long
[Music]
I'd like to but it says we're right here
the knee graph
Mr cook you're almost up are you ready
good I'm good
really going to need you to stick to the
script on this one I'm the CEO of Apple
Willis I'm not going to do anything
stupid please stop comparing me to Steve
Jobs no but nobody's comparing you to
Steve Jobs okay I just want you to focus
on the products and please stick to the
script okay you're on in three you're
gonna forget they ever heard the name
Steve Jobs
thing that I'm gonna do is
t-o-t-s throw out the scripts
now
I'm supposed to come out here and tell
you about some bull new iPhone pad pod
dick [ __ ] you've seen it I'm a bear I'm
a bear I'm a bit boring
yes that's exactly it
now let's just sit at this table right
here let's say it's Bill Gates huh
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about and let's
say that this is our competitors new
smartphone
[Music]
[Applause]
right and let's say that this right here
this is one of our competitors new eBook
reader huh what about that what uh-oh
looks like rain
thank you
yeah
all right
yes yes who wants to see some of that
classified next level
did Steve ever show you that classified
no we didn't you can't do that they
haven't been tested yet this device will
allow you to teleport anywhere on the
planet check this out I am the future
foreign
let's see Steve Jobs do that
I've been trying to reach out to you all
day
are we on for tonight
what you can't catch me you can't catch
me I'm Lance Moore touchdown [ __ ] what
pause
foreign
[Music]
sorry dude missed your texts
I assumed we'd meet at the bar
whatever I don't care
sorry dude missed your texts I assumed
we'd meet at the bar whatever I don't
care
whatever I don't care
is his problem
do you even want to hang out do you even
want to hang out oh that's considerate
like I said whatever like I said
whatever
this guy
Jesus you are priceless
you're the one who's priceless
this
this [ __ ] right here
oh he wants to oh okay
you want to go right now huh
guess I could do that
okay okay let's go he said okay okay
let's go all right you know what you
know what you want to really do this now
Keegan you nuts you're not putting me
out yeah let's do it oh yeah
[ __ ] first round's mine oh no
oh
no
buddy like I said first round's mine a
beer and a gimlet my partner right
what's that
uh I I got you a baseball bat with nails
in it
for my post-apocalyptic to Jackie
Robinson costume how did you know
hey baby oh wake up huh
what time is it
what are you doing good morning hey yo
come on girl it's time to get up let's
go
delete the picture [ __ ]
okay um uh Delete deleting it
um delete delete photo
okay
it's gone it's all it's all gone
thanks baby
scrambled
hey
we got this I'm sorry I'm talking at the
same time as you okay you go ahead and
talk I'm sorry go ahead no it's all
right
are you talking right now are you trying
to
go ahead this is
go ahead okay go ahead
all right I'm gonna talk and you just
keep okay it's you I'm sorry no
honestly my internet connection
are you talking right now
if it's a delay damn it okay
you go first and then no
what what's that what wait what
I can't believe this is not kidding me
not [ __ ] today ridiculous gotta have
this conversation
okay okay okay
did you catch up
or we wouldn't be talking at the same
time God damn
okay okay listen yeah you gotta stop
trying let me just look at the same time
or this conversation it's gonna just go
on
forever okay get out of it okay and
that's ridiculous I'm that no
you do no listen to me I don't know we
gotta end it we I gotta end there I
can't I can't do it anymore okay fine I
can't do it then we're gonna end it okay
we're gonna end okay I can't do it
Keegan
Keegan I'm gonna end it you're Frozen I
can't tell we're gonna end it okay
I just don't want you to be offended
ending it and oh
oh he really meant ended
[Music]
Decker
hey Jim Jackson
I'll be working with him on this mission
he's his exit
let's get one thing straight I don't
like orders and I don't play by the
rules I trust you heard of me actually
no I haven't
[Music]
we don't have much time the arachnid
agents have taken over the consulate we
need to get you in and resolve this from
the inside
we've taken the latest sit rep of the
hostels position and we've reconstructed
a holographic blueprint of the consulate
save the mouth squirt for the newer
occurs General
not going to be impressed by anything
technology
it's just a 3D representation
entered these days
Asian Jackson you will enter through
this AC duct on the south side of the
building yes sir Decker you will be
dropped on top and then you will gain
access through this Elevator Shaft we
want you to go down to the fourth floor
mate
[Music]
Decker
you okay
I heard everything you said
Elevator Shaft
it's bright yeah it's bright
the terrorists are located on the third
and fifth floor of the building each
floor has six groups of six men what
we're going to want you to do is stop in
the middle at the fourth and pry open
the elevator door and go
I just want you to move through that
elevator door and then go down
pry open
elevator door go down to the third floor
[Music]
okay maybe this isn't going to work out
why what's the matter General
everybody's putting their hand in the
laser
it's not a laser
it's a hologram
tomato tomato look what's with all the
babies sitting and hand holding
I was a big boy
let's zoom into the interior
[Music]
let's cut to the chase why am I here
your primary target is your old rival
from the Cold War
Nikolai andrakovich now Andrew kovich
has been leading
Jackson Jackson
good job Decker
Jackson was an undercover agent for
arachnid
how in the world did you know
all right in my day we made coffee hot
that's amazing amazing I know
we got it oh
[Applause]
dude you have absolutely mastered this
game well since um
Sheila left I've been spending a lot of
time
playing the game you're doing really
good thank you that's why we're here man
help you get over her and check out this
awesome new game you have
you know I left something in another
room um excuse me everyone
still has the sensors on I was like him
in his room yeah you can see him that's
funny what is he doing
is he is he on his knees did he drop to
his knee oh no no no he's probably
looking for no look he's he's crying
he's crying oh no he's just
he's shattering is he fetal yeah he
curled up look at that he's fatal hey
Craig buddy you all right up there oh
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah hey man you all right yes yeah
oh yeah yeah it's just that my sinuses
are acting up yeah yeah I um I was just
you know I was just thinking about
Sheila and you know what I am I am
totally over her awesome awesome that's
hey let's get this party started sure
oh
uh
I forgot to get rid of this picture
Sheila excuse me hey maybe leave the
sensor so one of us can play
oh he's dancing he's dancing with a
photo is he he's doing he's doing this
about it is he kissing it guys I think
he's kissing it you know what I'm gonna
turn this off because we don't need to
change it and you die
he's entering his Markle look at this
his pants are coming off his pants are
coming off oh God
no no no no no no no
okay that's happening oh no no no is he
he's he is totally on the bed he's
totally flat on the bed oh maybe he's
shaking a can of hairspray oh God
we shouldn't be okay you know is he
reaching down for his foot I know that's
his foot isn't it
and coming back come back
whoo
I am sorry everybody
[Music]
would you like me to make some snacks
wash your hands first
[Music]
[Music]